[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Thank you.
SPEAKER 2: So it's been a few
years since we had you in,
and the last time
you were here you
were speaking about
"NOPI: The Cookbook."
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: And it seems
like quite a change
or a shift in terms of
a restaurant cookbook
to this being--
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: This, yeah.
SPEAKER 2: --a home cookbook.
Tell us a little
bit about the shift.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: It's like
the two ends of the spectrum
of Ottolenghi cookbooks.
So on the one hand you have
"NOPI," and on the other hand,
you have "Simple."
And it's a little bit the
story of my personal journey.
So the books really
don't come in any--
they're a bit random
in the way they
come out, because they are--
the reasons why a certain book
comes out at a certain time
has a lot to do with
the people that I
collaborate with on the books
and what we feel like doing.
And with "NOPI" that
was out two years ago,
it was Scully, who's
the head chef there, was
really eager to put
all that creative stuff
that has gone into the making
of that restaurant into a book.
And we were starting
writing down recipes.
And I said to the
publishers, look,
we've got to do this now,
because this is happening.
And so that came out.
And then "Simple,"
which is, like I said,
the other end of the spectrum,
which is really geared towards
home cooks and also a much more
comfortable way of cooking with
ease and simplicity-- and
we can talk more about that
in a minute--
came about after I've had
a couple of supplements
with "The Guardian."
So "The Guardian" called me.
I publish recipes in "The
Guardian" every weekend,
but a few years ago my
editor called me and said,
I'd like 20 easy recipes for
the spring for a supplement.
And I went like,
I don't do simple.
I'm sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
And I don't do easy either.
Because it just seems
so weird to even
start thinking like that.
Because I've never
had to convince anyone
that it's not worth your
while spending all this time
in the kitchen to get something
as good as what I thought
I put there.
But I said, OK,
we'll think about it.
And I sat down with
my two collaborators
on the book, Tara
and Esme, who have
been part of this process
for quite a while.
And we just started
talking about what
might be our 20 simple or
easy recipes for the spring.
There were also
ingredient-- number
of ingredients was
limited, et cetera.
And we just had so much fun.
So we all brought our
little tricks from home--
things from cans and frozen.
And Esme, who has been cooking
for many years on boats--
she was cooking on yachts
for about 10 years,
she had all these
nifty tricks about--
obviously, you can't spend a
lot of time and everything needs
to be very solid,
and well-grounded,
as you can imagine, on boats--
had her set of
ideas on what to do.
And within 20 minutes, we had
20 ideas but really cool things
that we were very proud
of doing, and it was fun.
And sometimes, I'm sure
it's applicable to almost
every field of human
creation, when you've
got this set of
limitations, it actually
makes you more creative.
So it was like, OK, we need
to make it simple in some way.
And that's how the
supplements came about,
and that's how the book
came about as a result
of those "Guardian" supplements.
But the other
thing that had also
happened that led to
this book, or the way
the book has shaped
up to be this thing,
was that last year another
cookery writer, Diana Henry,
came up with a book
called "Simple."
And I saw that,
and I go, oh, gosh.
No.
What do we do now?
Because she's just
stolen my title.
[LAUGHTER]
And it happened to us already
before, really weirdly
and bizarrely, when
"Plenty" came out, which
is six years ago, I think, now.
I published that book and
I got a really angry--
not really angry but frustrated
email from her, saying,
"My next book was
going to be 'Plenty--'"
[LAUGHTER]
--which is-- it's funny.
So she had to find a
derivative title with the word
"plenty" in it, and now I
call this book "Ottolenghi
Simple" rather than "Simple."
And I was really
happy to do that,
because what it made us think
is we sat down and thought,
what makes "Ottolenghi
Simple" simple?
So obviously we had
to complicate things.
[LAUGHTER]
And so we said--
SPEAKER 2: So tell us about
the philosophy behind "Simple."
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah, so
I'll tell you about the extra
complication that we added
to the simple notion,
and that's the coding
system with the S-I-M-P-L-E.
And essentially what we tried
to do is we started talking
to people around
us and asked them,
what is simple cooking for you?
And we got really
different answers.
So some would say,
oh, you know, it's
about coming home and putting
a dish on the table within 20
minutes or half an hour.
And some other people said,
I don't want to go shopping.
I just want to cook it
from things that I really
have lurking around-- a packet
of rice, a couple of lemons,
and some garlic, things that
you make from what you've got.
Others said, I really
want to cook everything
in advance, so either
for weekend cooking,
or for weekday cooking
or for weekend cooking.
I just want to make
sure everything is ready
and then I just put it
out or put it together
at the very last minute.
So there were very
different notions
of what simple cooking is.
And, hence, the S-I-M-P-L-E,
and each one is a different
category of recipes in the book.
S stands for short--
short on time, so anything that
would take 20 minutes, half
an hour to cook.
The I stands for ingredients--
10 or less, which, in
my world, 10 or less
is really the bare minimum.
[LAUGHTER]
This is not Jamie
Oliver's "5 Ingredients."
The M stands for make ahead.
SPEAKER 2: Make
ahead of time, yeah.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: The P stands
for pantry, so we cover that--
rice, pasta, couscous,
everything that is frozen--
frozen peas, frozen
corn and things.
It sounds terrible,
but actually those
are some of my favorite
dishes in the book.
The L stands for lazy,
and lazy is those--
and it's not you being lazy.
It's just the attitude of
being lazy when you want to be.
And those are recipes that cook
themselves-- stews and roasts.
And so you put it there.
You go read a book.
You come back and
you've got a meal.
And the E is an extra
category that we
added which is called
"Easier Than you Think."
And that is more about a state
of mind than anything else.
So for me, one of
the reasons why
people are a little
bit intimidated
by certain ways of
cooking is because they've
gotten into their heads that
they can't cook this thing,
or they're not bakers, or they--
those notions.
And cooking, like many other
things, is 90% psychology.
And the E is like an ice cream.
You never thought you were going
to make ice cream if you don't
have an ice cream maker
sitting on-- churn ice cream,
or it's a quick bread that
you can do even if you're not
a baker, or certain desserts.
It's also things that have
like a complicated French name,
like a confit or
something like that.
You think that's
just for restaurants,
but that's not for me.
But actually it could be.
So yeah, that's the system.
So every recipe in the book
would have at least one
of those marks but
could have more of them.
Some recipes are
all six of them.
SPEAKER 2: So if I
wanted to make something
in under 30 minutes, I
would look for everything
with the S symbol--
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: With
the S on it, yeah.
SPEAKER 2: --and attempt.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
So that would be--
that's the way.
It's really about-- and so
we were talking just now.
I'm doing a podcast
at the moment
called "Simple Pleasures."
And the podcast came
about from the same series
of conversations that we were
having about simple cooking.
And I wanted to just
expand that a little bit
into other conversations with
people that either they're
from food or they're
not from food
but can say
something about, what
does it mean to cook or live
simply, or with more ease?
And so I expanded
this from kitchens
to other areas of life.
And I've got people coming on
the podcast and talking to me
about what they do--
what makes them at ease,
or what other
aspects of their life
apart from what
they're famous for.
They've pared down or
loosened up a little bit.
And I think it's just
really refreshing
sometimes to talk about this.
Because for me, I meet a lot
of cooks, and many of them
talked about anxiety
when it comes to food.
And for me, the idea of
mixing cooking with anxiety
is really counterintuitive,
because cooking
should be the one thing
that de-stresses, right?
That's why I got into the
kitchen-- to de-stress.
And I think this should
be the whole story.
There shouldn't be anything
beyond the de-stressing
in the kitchen.
But because cooking is
also used to impress,
and people put a lot of pressure
on themselves to impress,
often it's about reinventing
yourself every time
you walk into the kitchen,
and that is really stressful.
I couldn't do it, to create
a meal from a cuisine
that you haven't even tasted.
And you want to
do that sometimes,
but essentially, it really
isn't the way forward.
The way forward, if you want
to use the kitchen and a tool
to inject some more
ease, as I said,
or simplicity, or a sense
of, yeah, simplicity,
then you actually
want to cook something
that you have cooked
before, or something
that is very familiar,
or something that
is just a second nature to you.
Nigella, who was on my
podcast, called it competence.
And she says
competence doesn't seem
like a-- it's not a sexy word.
Although when she says
it, of course it's sexy.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's not a sexy word.
But it means that you just do
something over and over again
and become really good at it.
And then you get
over all those issues
that stand in the way of putting
a good meal on the table.
And I think I personally
prefer to go to someone's house
knowing that I might have
something at that friend's
house that I've had before,
but it's really good, right?
I don't care that I've
had it maybe last year.
It's absolutely fine.
SPEAKER 2: But I certainly
suffer from that anxiety
where I don't cook that much.
So it's a matter
of-- you're right.
I need to practice.
How many times do
you think I'd need
to cook a dish 'til I put my
own twist to yours, for example?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
So essentially, it depends
on what you choose to cook.
So for instance,
I've got two recipes
in the book for baked rice.
Baked rice is a really
cool way to cook rice.
You know many people
don't have a rice cooker
and haven't come from
an Asian culture are
a little bit intimidated by
cooking rice, because it's
quite easy to overcook or
to not have enough liquid.
So you don't want your
rice to be al dente.
So baked rice is
a really good way.
You throw a lot of things in a
roasting tray or baking tray,
and you seal it with foil
and stick it in the oven,
and you can leave it there
for longer than you think.
It isn't strictly
necessary and it
won't really spoil or anything.
And it's really a good
way to infuse rice
with lots of flavor, because
you've got a lot of surface
there, so you can put--
I add mint leaves, or
cinnamon, or garlic,
and it just spreads
through the rice.
Essentially, the
cooking liquids turn
into really aromatic, beautiful
aromatic stock that just
makes the rice so delicious.
And then what you choose
to do with that rice
is really up to you.
So once you've
mastered this kind
of very simple technique of
cooking rice by baking it,
you--
SPEAKER 2: I add my own--
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: It's
easy to improvise.
There is one recipe
here for rice
that I just cook all
the time at the moment.
It's the one with the tomatoes,
that actually the version
of which is served today here.
But I don't know if they
followed it strictly.
[LAUGHTER]
But essentially-- because
when you cook for a big crowd,
you don't really do that.
But you take cherry
tomatoes and garlic cloves
and some shallots,
and you throw them
in with cinnamon and olive oil,
and you put it in the oven.
That's one of the lazy
recipes, because you just
leave it there for 20 minutes
and then those vegetables just
cook and flavor the oil.
And then you throw a packet
of rice in and some water
and you put foil and let
it do its thing again
for another 25 minutes.
So it takes time but
essentially very little effort.
And you get a whole beautiful,
fragrant meal for rice.
It's got everything there.
It's got the vegetables.
It's got the rice.
You can add something else,
but it's super delicious.
And I do it every
weekend because I
know people love it and
it is very, very easy.
I can go and play with the kids
while this is doing its thing.
SPEAKER 2: I wanted us to talk
a little bit about the pantry.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: The P. Your
pantry is likely to be
very different from mine.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: So--
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Most
people's, I guess.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: What's the
philosophy behind the pantry?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: So the pantry
is-- at the back of the book,
we listed a list.
There's a list of
about 10 ingred--
not about, exactly 10
ingredients-- that are--
this is the contract you
sign when you buy the book.
You've got to get
these 10 ingredients.
[LAUGHTER]
And believe me, narrowing
it down to 10 from 100
was quite hard.
But actually, the
idea is often people--
the number one complaint at the
bottom of my "Guardian" column
comments, which I don't
look at but people tell me--
[LAUGHTER]
--is those ingredients.
My god, where do you
get the ingredients?
So I address this in this
book as well by saying, OK,
there's 10 ingredients.
That's not a lot to buy.
It's not even expensive.
You buy them and they take you
quite a long way in the book,
so they will reappear
in different recipes.
So some of them would
be familiar to people
who have been cooking my
recipes, like sumac and za'atar
that you mentioned,
preserved lemon.
There's also black
garlic, which is
a slightly more recent edition.
Tahini, of course, but it
has to be a good tahini.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
Well, so what's good tahini?
What gets the Ottolenghi
tick of approval?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI:
Good tahini is--
well, I always get into
trouble because there's
a bit of a chauvinism about
my appreciation of tahini
that comes from my
part of the Middle East
rather than other
parts of the world.
So I would say here now, and all
the Greeks and Cypriots, close
your ears.
[LAUGHTER]
Greek tahini is not good.
It's grainy and it's not--
SPEAKER 2: I see a
future where Greek tahini
sales are plummeting.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: No.
The thing is there
is a brand that you
find in many supermarkets
called Cypressa.
And it's just not-- sorry.
I don't want to get anyone--
I should probably shut
my mouth now, but--
SPEAKER 2: Well, what's good?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Maybe--
SPEAKER 2: Let's
shift to what's good.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI:
Yeah, maybe it's
the tahini from Lebanon or
Palestinian or Israeli tahinis.
They're just better.
The sesame seeds are
toasted properly,
so it's nice and
brown and luscious.
And also there's no grain
in it, so all the husks
are properly removed, so
it's really, really smooth.
And for me, the sesame
being really good
and tahini being really smooth
are what makes a good tahini
a really good tahini.
And once you've tried a proper
one or a really good tahini,
you realize how good it is.
It's a bit like olive oil.
There's a whole range from
very good to not that great.
And I'm not going to mention
countries that have--
[LAUGHTER]
--bad olive oil.
But actually, it isn't
about the country.
It's about how it's being done.
So that's a good tahini.
So going back to
the 10 ingredients,
we narrowed it down to 10.
And those 10 ingredients,
for this particular book,
the building blocks
of the pantry
that I'd like people to have.
They're not necessary, and you'd
find recipes that are literally
cauliflower and that's about
it, and butter and oil,
and you don't need to
get a fancy pantry.
But those 10 ingredients are
really cool to have, and, yeah.
That is it.
And the other
elements in the pantry
are things that I think
normal pantries will have.
SPEAKER 2: Right.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Rice,
pasta, frozen peas, you know,
those kind of things.
SPEAKER 2: So the
Ottolenghi 10 ingredients
still retain the Ottolenghi-ness
despite perhaps the title being
a bit of an oxymoron,
for some people at least.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah,
the oxymoron in the title
is the one thing I'm trying
to combat by doing that.
And, yeah, I mean, I do
think that we managed
to find ways to make the
recipes enough Ottolenghi
without disappointing anyone,
so keeping the surprise
element, the idea that something
is a little bit challenging
but, at the same
time, also comforting,
which has always been
at the top of my agenda.
So to make an Ottolenghi
recipe, which is funny
that I say that--
that's my surname--
but I get that there is
something beyond that.
It's got a life of its own now.
SPEAKER 2: It's a brand.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
And it means that
it can't just be--
I'm not saying it in
any prerogative way,
but it's not a
Nigel Slater recipe.
No, those are like a
really good pea soup.
It's just it won't
cut the mustard,
so it needs to have some
kind of twist or something
a bit unpredictable or, like I
said, a surprise to make it fit
or stand up to the
expectations of what people
have from cooking my food.
SPEAKER 2: So I know we
spoke about 10 ingredients,
but let's say you
could only have one.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: One.
SPEAKER 2: One, one
ingredient that defines--
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI:
I think it needs
to be that lemon on the
cover and on my T-shirt.
SPEAKER 2: Yes.
Love the T-shirt.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
Because you can do
so much with a lemon.
And I think people who
have been cooking recipes
that I've published
over the years
would know that there
is a lot of things
that I do with lemons that are--
so there's the juicing and
the zesting and the grating
and infusing it.
But there's also various ways
to roast it and add it to salads
and to preserve it, so there's
preserved lemons there.
And so I still
think there's ways
with lemon that I
haven't discovered yet
that I'm waiting to
discover, because it's just
such a great ingredient.
And it does encompass
quite a lot of my cooking,
if it has to be one ingredient.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
I want to talk a bit
more about the cookbook.
So I find that this may be
the cookbook that I cook most
from out of all of the ones.
Do you have any
favorite recipes?
Because as I said, I love the--
there's a dish called
Hot Charred Tomatoes
with Cold Yogurt, which is
so delicious and really easy
to make.
And the first time
where I think I've
only had to run to the
shops and buy the tomatoes.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: I had everything
else in the kitchen.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Did you?
SPEAKER 2: Yes.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
Yeah, this set of ingredients
is quite common, I'd say.
Recipes that I love
from the book--
so it's the things that
I cook quite often,
is there is a pasta dish
with harissa, olive, capers.
And it's a North African
inspired set of ingredients.
And so I took the liberty
to add some yogurt when
I serve it, which
is not very Italian,
and pasta is considered
to be an Italian thing.
But the connections between
North Africa and Southern Italy
are really very,
very evident when
you go to places like Sicily
or Sardinia or southern Italy.
So it is a recipe that is
a hybrid of those two food
cultures.
And I make it.
There's a really good brand
of rose harissa from Belazu.
That's a really good brand, and
you find them in supermarkets
now.
And it really doesn't
entail much more
than getting that and some
tomatoes and, like I said,
capers, olives.
And it just creates the
most incredible pasta.
And you could put
it on the table
within the time it
takes to cook the pasta,
or just a little bit
longer than that.
So that's a favorite.
There's also a
recipe that I really
love which is a little
bit more personal.
It's Gnocchi alla Romana.
SPEAKER 2: Mm.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: It's
Semollina gnocchi.
It's not gnocchi from potato
that most people might know,
but it's made with semolina.
And my grandmother, who was
Italian, used to make that.
And again, some people who
grew up in this country
have a really negative
association with semolina
because it's been served
in some schools, I hear.
It was part of the
not-so-loved repertoire
of school canteens
in this country,
but luckily I was spared that.
I arrived late enough to
not have to go through this.
But semolina is a
great ingredient.
It absorbs flavors.
It's really very
smooth and beautiful.
In Indian cooking, you find
great ways with semolina.
And so, essentially,
the semolina
is cooked with Parmesan,
and butter, and some nutmeg,
and then made into
little circles.
And those are put under the
grill with some more cheese.
You don't really
have to say much more
than that to make you--
SPEAKER 2: Yes, I'm
getting very hungry.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: So that's
another favorite recipe.
But there's also desserts.
There's a blueberry
and lemon loaf
cake, which really could
be anyone's, really.
I just think it's a
really good recipe.
And I put that together
really quickly.
And it's nice to have a
cake with very little effort
in the house.
SPEAKER 2: Great.
Let's shift gears and talk a
little bit about other things.
So I follow your
social media accounts,
and you post lots of pictures
from your test kitchen.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: So at
Google, obviously, we're
all about the innovation.
I want to understand how you
go about developing recipes,
because you basically do
it as a full-time job.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
I am.
Really, I develop recipes
as a full-time job.
Well, that's how I feel
most of my time now.
I go to the restaurants a
lot, too, and try the recipes.
But I don't cook
in the restaurants.
My way of developing recipes
has really evolved over time.
So when I started
testing recipes,
I used to do it all
from my kitchen at home.
I used to live in West London,
and I had a small kitchen.
Up until the book, "Plenty," I
tested every recipe by myself
at home.
I used to take my car,
go to the supermarket,
buy the ingredients, cook, write
the recipe, do the washing up.
And it was a very inefficient
way of producing recipes.
But since I only needed to
come up with one recipe a week,
it was kind of doable.
But also, the other
problem was that I
found it really difficult
to get inspired in this way.
So I would sit with things
and have conversations.
But really, it was kind of
a lonesome way of working.
And about 10 years ago, we
started the test kitchen,
which you're talking about,
which it's not a very--
if you come there, it's not
a very glamorous environment.
It's not a Google
head office, but we
made it really look like
anyone's kitchen in the sense
that it's a very
low tech kitchen.
The philosophy behind
that is because I
don't want to create
something that people
won't recreate at home.
SPEAKER 2: Right.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI:
So the ingredients
come from just
ordinary supermarkets.
And the equipment
is basic equipment.
And I know a lot of people
have fancy equipment
at home, but not everybody.
And I want to know what is
the basic result that people
would get when I try something.
That was the idea
behind the test kitchen.
And I've got a team now
of about three people
and sometimes more, because
chefs come from the restaurants
to try their recipes there, too.
And it's become a great,
creative hub, because people--
so I've got my team that
develop recipes for books
and other publications.
I've got the chefs coming
from the restaurants.
And the conversations are just
really, really interesting.
So if something comes
up in one environment,
it's completely
relevant immediately
to the other
environment but needs
to be changed and evolved.
Like, for instance,
Rovi is a restaurant
that I opened a few
months ago in Fitzrovia,
actually not that far from here.
SPEAKER 2: Which is
great, by the way.
We'll get onto that.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: And we did a
lot of pickling and preserving
for that.
Because we were working on
recipes for the restaurant way
before it opened.
And the notion of seasonality
was not so clear at that point,
because we didn't know whether
we were going to open in June
or whether it was
going to be September,
and things really change.
So we pickled quite a lot
of stuff and fermented
and made sure that we--
the restaurant is focused on a
grill on which we grill mostly
vegetables but also
some meat and fish.
And we wanted to get
those really enticing,
strong flavors.
But like I said,
we didn't really
know exactly when it
was going to open,
so we had to
preserve and ferment.
For home cooks, that's quite a
big investment for the future,
because it takes days
and weeks for things
to kind of come to their own.
And so we tested
little shortcuts.
We've got a Chilean
tomato ferment, which
is one of my favorite,
and we served it
with mint as a condiment to
many of the dishes in Rovi.
We took certain shortcuts.
Often, we would use--
you add a little bit of vinegar
and a little bit of sugar, not
a lot, but just a tiny
bit to get it started.
And then you leave
it for one day
or not as long as
that, et cetera.
So those are conversations
that we constantly have.
So everybody tries
recipes, and we all
get together when it's time to
taste and taste and comment.
Very meticulous notes
are being taken down.
Because for me, recipes,
they have to work.
I know it sounds really
like it's common sense,
but I know it's not, because
some recipes don't work.
We test it a lot.
Once that's done, there is
a woman who lives in Wales
and has got a few kids, and a
husband, and extended family.
And she tests the
recipes on her family.
Only once that comes back
to me with a completely set
of comments that are
satisfying, the recipe
is released to the world.
So it's a very long process
with various stages.
SPEAKER 2: Sounds like the
Google hiring process almost.
How many make the cut?
2 out of 10 recipes
that make the cut?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: When they
get to her, most of them make--
I would never send something
that I'm not really
100% happy with.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: And I
learned from my experience
that normally, if I have some
doubts, then she confirms them.
Claudine, who is my
recipe tester in Wales,
she cooked every dish
I've ever published.
It's 1,000 recipes now.
She really knows what the
level is and the expectations.
And she has very honest
people around her also
confirming what she thinks.
So normally they come fine.
But I have a way of
reading what she says.
I do want the truth, you know?
When it's excellent, I loved
it, there's no problem.
But sometimes she writes, nice.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: And she's
English, so nice is--
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: She's
half French, half English.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI:
But nice is kind of--
so if I had a tiny bit of
doubt about that recipe when
it went to her and it
came back with a nice,
then we take it back, and try
it again, and put a big question
mark around it and ask,
do we really love it?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI:
Because you really
need to love the recipes
that go out there,
because people cook them.
They go buy the ingredients,
feed their friends and family.
You really want them to
be pretty spectacular,
because otherwise, why?
SPEAKER 2: Well, I'll
ask one more question,
but I would ask Googlers to
have your questions ready.
There's a microphone
waiting there.
My last question is going
to be about food trends.
So it feels like veganism is
a really big thing right now.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: You've been an early
supporter, I would say, I mean,
with "Plenty", "Plenty More."
You've been flying the plant
flag for a very long time now.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: So do you
think it's going to last?
And what are your thoughts
about trends in general?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
So for me, the interest in
vegetarian and vegan food
has always been a result of
not so much of an agenda,
but just because I think there
is just so much there that
could be enjoyed.
And so the idea of turning
a non-vegan recipe vegan
is not something
that I enjoy doing.
So vegan meat, or vegan
risotto, or anything
that even just feels like
you're adapting something
is not something
that I do naturally.
Because the culture
that I come from,
or the general Middle
Eastern food culture,
has a lot of recipes that
are just naturally vegan.
And in other parts of the
world, that's also the case.
So I think those are
the good vegan dishes.
I didn't really
love tofu until I
went traveling in Southeast
Asia and understood
what to do with tofu.
It took a while for
me to warm up to tofu
and see how well it
should be prepared.
Once I've seen it, I
realized that tofu is not
a substitute to meat by any
stretch of the imagination.
It's a real, proper foodstuff
in China, and Malaysia,
and Singapore, and other
places in Southeast Asia.
And it's fantastic,
but you really
need to know what
you're doing with it.
So I think veganism is great.
I think there will be more
people having a vegan diet.
But I think the
strict vegan diet
and the strict kind
of vegan way of life,
that I didn't really enjoy in
its earliest incarnation, which
was kind of about, like
I said, translating
other foods into
the vegan language,
is not something that I think
will stay for a very long time.
But I think what will
become more and more evident
is that people want to eat
more and more vegan dishes
but not strictly vegan.
And that's what you see
people say quite a lot.
I've talked quite a lot
about flexitarianism.
It's a word that people use.
It sounds a bit like something
you'd put as a headline,
but it stands for something
much deeper than that.
It's an understanding
that you need
to change your way
of eating, but you
need to be also
practical about it,
that there's human
nature, that we're humans,
that we have certain
inclinations, that we
make certain sacrifices.
So I think that would be the
way we see veganism transforming
itself, reinventing itself
going into the future.
SPEAKER 2: And also
of plants just being
celebrated, like in Rovi, the
things that you do with corn,
for example.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah,
with corn, or with celeriac,
or with cauliflower,
or with courgettes.
Like what I said about lemon--
that I'm just feeling like
I'm scraping the surface--
is true about other vegetables.
And I think vegetables
also have more potential
to do interesting things
with them than meat and fish,
because meat and fish are
really great as they are.
You put a bit of oil and
salt and you grill it,
and you've got
something delicious.
But vegetables, it
takes a little bit more.
But once you start, you
get way more flavor.
And the techniques
of cooking are
much more diverse in "Plenty
More" which is an older book
that I published.
It was all about how
cooking techniques really
create very different results
with the same vegetables.
SPEAKER 2: With that, let's
take some audience questions.
Don't be shy.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Google
people cannot be shy.
SPEAKER 2: Yes, come on.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: That
is not possible, is it?
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
Thanks for joining us today.
My question is, what is
your take on sustainability.
Specifically, does things
like locally sourced, produced
or organic materials--
how much does that factor into
the recipes you come up with?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: It has become
increasingly more relevant
to me over the years.
I think it's definitely
not been high on my agenda
when I started writing cookbooks
and cooking in general.
But like many other
people, I've come
to realize how important
it is to keep this in mind.
And again, the way I
spoke about veganism,
I feel a little bit the
same about sustainability.
You need to be careful
how you apply it,
because there is a tendency
to look at things at extremes
and black and white.
So trading in spices
has been something
that has been going on for a
very long time, for millennia,
and we'll keep on doing.
And I think it's a good thing.
Importing water
from Fiji has not
happened for a very
long time and I
think is not a good thing.
And I think, in
between those two,
there's a whole
range of behaviors
that we need to kind of look at.
And it's becoming
more and more evident
that we need to do much less
on the non-sustainable level
than we do.
But I'm being very
pragmatic about it.
One of the things that we're
doing a lot at Rovi, but also
in the other restaurants,
is working with farmers
from the area
southeast of England.
And the partnerships
are really incredible.
So things like shiso
leaves, which are really
kind of Japanese,
are grown in Dorset,
and we get them
within a few hours.
And so it's just really
beneficial, and useful,
and good to think that way.
Because you constantly discover
things that are possible that
you haven't.
But as far as I can tell,
coffee will never come from UK.
SPEAKER 2: I hope not.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI:
But we will still
carry on enjoying coffees, but
hopefully not in paper cups
but in glass cups that we can
bring with us to the coffee
shop.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can I become a recipe tester?
[LAUGHTER]
Number two, you
mentioned a family.
How do you create a sense of
fun, creativity, curiosity
at home when it comes
to food and cooking?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah,
it's really difficult.
I've got two boys
that are young.
They're three years
old and five years old.
Had you asked me this question
before I had children,
I had this kind of ideal notion
that I'd just put everything
on the table and
let them experience.
And they'll eat what you
eat and all the rest.
It doesn't really
work like that.
So the new version of this
theory, the slightly more
realistic version of
this theory is that, yes,
I do adapt things
for my children.
Like any other
child that I know,
their first [INAUDIBLE]
these ages, I mean,
is a bowl of pasta, pasta
with tomato sauce and cheese.
And I'd give them
that all the time.
I put other things around,
and we eat other things,
and we get them excited.
But I think showing
them what's going on
is really, really useful.
Because children are
just naturally curious,
I mean, way more
curious than adults.
If you're going to
pickle something,
they will just ask
lots of question
before they even think it's
something that they will eat.
So just opening a kind of
window to the way things are
is really useful.
And it doesn't mean
you need to cook a lot.
It just means that when you
cook, you just expose it.
Or even just talking about
this or being interested,
I think that is the
first step to get
kids involved in this world.
It shows how middle
class we are,
but Max, my oldest son came
back from school last year
and said to me, oh, I
know how to make sushi.
So they were rolling
sushi at school.
I said, really?
That's interesting.
I don't know how to make sushi.
And I think he was really
proud of being able to be there
at that moment.
You can do all sorts
of things like that.
Give them a little job.
Let them do it.
You might not even cook
that thing that they did.
But it's just getting
them involved, I think,
is really, really important.
AUDIENCE: Do you ever
experience the chef version
of writer's block?
And how do you overcome it?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
So I do and I did.
I did more, but now--
so this goes back
to the test kitchen,
which is I don't
think I actually
finished developing
this idea about how
the creative process happens.
I stopped at how strict
we are at testing recipes,
but I didn't really talk
about the creative process.
And this is really interesting,
because, like I said,
when I stopped
working singularly
and I started
working in a group,
I found that it's really
helpful for everybody.
It's very helpful for
me, that's for sure.
Because every person brings
their own story, history,
palette to the conversation,
which is great.
But it's also what
happens when you
talk about an idea in a
group and how it evolves.
So often we go, oh, no,
it's asparagus season again.
It's the dreaded thing,
because in Britain, we
don't have a lot of things
that are really seasonal
and really off the plate,
and asparagus is one of them.
And gooseberries is another one.
But there's like, how many
columns about asparagus
can you write?
But actually, when you sit
down with three or four people
and you talk about
columns, it's incredible
how much comes through those
particular conversations,
much more than you'd think would
come out of you if you haven't
had those people around.
So one person's idea
sparks an idea in your mind
that you didn't
really even have.
And you develop it into
something completely different.
Jeremy Lee, who is a
chef that I really like,
rolls his asparagus in
phyllo and just sprinkles it
with Parmesan and
fries it or bakes it.
It's a really great dish.
And I just had that
in my mind when
we had the latest asparagus
discussion, which was probably
in January or something.
And that idea of rolling
the asparagus in something
could completely take you to a
completely different direction.
It's an image more
than anything else.
But it's something that
you can just use or take.
You can coat it
with something which
isn't a pastry or anything.
So those conversations
are really, really useful
in the group--
starting with one
thought and then kind
of just rolling
into something else.
And so that's how the recipes
evolve from those conversations
and from tasting.
SPEAKER 2: We'll take
two more questions.
Yes, go on.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm not exactly the best cook,
maybe not even very good.
Have you got any
kitchen cheats or hacks
that could help my skill level?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: First
of all, I want to say,
before I give you
a bit of advice,
it's funny how it goes
back to the discussion
that we had about
cooking at ease.
There is a real pressure
to be good at everything.
And cooking is not something
you need to be good at.
There's so many
good places to eat--
[LAUGHTER]
--all around, everywhere.
I feel that there's this
pressure for everybody to cook.
And I know a lot of
people that don't really
love cooking that much, and
it's really not a problem.
So you're in a safe space.
It's absolutely fine.
My sister, when I came
up with this book,
she said to me, oh, my God,
finally I can cook your food.
I don't think it's her
number one leisure activity.
She's got three kids.
She's got a busy job, a busy
life, and she just didn't cook.
This book is full
of tricks for you.
And I think one of those
things I can only say
is that if you see a
recipe that says to you,
I want to eat that,
that's step one.
That's really important.
And the next step is just
read carefully through
and see there's nothing
challenging or too
overcomplicated and try it.
I think that is the
best way around it.
There is a dish here,
another pasta dish.
I think that's a very
good place to start.
It's got tinned chickpeas,
za'atar, and olive oil.
And those are all
cupboard ingredients,
and it's something you can
put together very quickly.
And you can be really
proud of your achievement
and not feel that you've cheated
in a very substantial way.
Because again, it
doesn't matter.
Because when people taste
it and say it's amazing,
you don't need to tell
them how easy it was.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Hey.
AUDIENCE: So what's next
for you for the next one-
to five-year plan?
[LAUGHS]
SPEAKER 2: Googlers
really like actions.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: That is
kind of a long trajectory.
Well, I don't really know.
And that's a very
genuine answer,
because I have never had a plan.
So there is definitely going
to be a book coming out,
not next year because
I'm taking a year off,
because it's been too much.
But the year after
that, I'm going
to have another book coming.
And that book will explore
the notion of flexitarianism
that I talked about.
So I don't want to
reveal too much of it.
But I think a little
bit that you can be--
and don't quote me on that--
a vegetarian and you can
still use fish sauce.
No, probably not.
But the notion that
you could choose
that kind of line of
eating and cooking
is the way I'm exploring now.
So it's kind of flavor
ideas of flavor bombs
that could really enhance
your vegetable-focused meal
and turn them into something
super delicious is what I'm
thinking about for that book.
But it's really
just the beginning,
because I've got
a couple of years
to work on that-- or
a year and a half.
And then I don't really
know, I have to be honest.
I don't think we're going
to open another restaurant
for at least another
two or three years,
because restaurants
are a nightmare.
Even successful restaurants,
behind the scenes,
are a nightmare, because
it's just really difficult
to run a restaurant.
And with Brexit, we
also have less people
coming through the door to
take the jobs that we need.
So it's become increasingly
more difficult.
But the restaurants
are doing well,
so there probably will be
another one at some point.
But there isn't one
planned for any time
in the very near future.
SPEAKER 2: Will you
expand internationally?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI:
Expand internationally?
This is a conversation that
we've had a lot in the past.
And the difficulty with
that is that, first of all,
it's a lifestyle choice.
So that means
someone needs to be
going from one
country to the other
all the time to make
sure it's done properly.
The other is the
quality control.
So you need to
partner with someone
that really understands
the ethos and how it works.
And I know there's a lot
of chefs that do that.
Some do it really well.
Others failed.
So there's all sorts
of examples of how
that international
expansion plays out.
But it's a possibility.
And like I say, I can't
tell how many conversations
I've been in when we
discussed that option
and then dismissed it
on all sorts of grounds.
So I don't know yet.
We'll see.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
Well, I think we may
have to wrap it up.
A few closing comments from me--
Cafe Royal is
celebrating the book,
and they've cooked at least
a dozen dishes for you
to try out, which is great.
Yotam has a podcast, which
is actually really excellent.
You can find it on Spotify.
Features guests such
as Lin-Manuel Miranda,
Nigella Lawson, Nadia Hussain.
Great to listen to.
And last but not least,
already a bestselling book,
so hopefully you
will enjoy the dishes
and go out and buy the book.
But can you please
join me in thanking
Yotam for coming in today?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]